[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen am
Fliegerhorst Hinterstoisser in Zeltweg
der Heimat des Eurofighter Taifun 2000
des österreichischen Bundesheeres und
herzlich willkommen im 21 Jahrhundert
mein Name ist Patrick Wöss bin vom
Dienstgrad der Oberleutnant 30 Jahre und
ich bin einsatzpilot am System
Eurofighter ich darf euch heute auf ein
Rundgang um den Eurofighter mitnehmen
schauen wie der Eurofighter ausgestattet
ist was man alles zu sehen kann wie er
funktioniert grundsätzlich dafür mal
sagen zum eurofight der ist ein
Kampfflugzeug der vierten Generation und
er ist ein swing-roll Fighters swingroll
bedeutet das dass der Eurofighter
gleichzeitig in derselben Mission
Luftziele und Bodenziele bekämpfen kann
es ist quasi ein Flieger der alles kann
und damit man alles kann braucht man
sehr viel Ausrüstung und diese
Ausrüstung sehen wir uns jetzt in einem
Rundgang an
ist grundsätzlich ein fly bei
weiherflieger das heißt es gibt keine
Steuerstange mehr wie man sich das
vorstellt der Pilot ist mit
Steuerknüppel nicht mehr Star mit den
Steuerflächen verbunden das heißt der
Computer oder der Flieger wird nur noch
durch Computer gesteuert Eurofighter ist
im unterschallbereich ein sehr labiles
Flugzeug das braucht auch damit mit
meinem Luftkampf schnell um die Kurve
kommen und damit wir da siegreich
hervorgehen im transsonischen Bereich
zwischen sprich im Bereich um mach eins
um die einfache Schallgeschwindigkeit
wird er dann indifferent und im
Überschall ist er dann sehr stabil das
brauchen wir folgen wenn man lange
Strecken zurücklegen und sehr sehr hoch
fliegen und jetzt schauen wir uns an wie
der Flieger des macht und was wir dazu
brauchen aufgrund der hohen Agilität des
Fliegers und der reinen hergehen denn
Labilität ist es für den Flieger sehr
sehr wichtig dass immer weiß wie hoch
das er ist wie schnell das ist und wo er
ist Aufschluss darüber gibt den Flight
Control Computer sprich den Computer der
den Flieger aktiv
steuerbar hält und stabil hält
diese Geräte hier das sind die
sogenannten Edits die eher data
transducer der Arbeiter hat vier davon
und nimmt aus der Luft alle Daten die er
braucht das bleibt Kontrollsystem
spricht das System das dem Flieger am
Fliegen hält ist vierfach Redundanz ist
quadrupel redundant besteht aus vier
Computern und wir können drei Computer
ausfallen und der Flieger fliegt immer
noch also es ist sehr sehr resistent
gegenüber Ausfallserscheinungen des
Weiteren sehen wir hier gleich nach
vorne die triebwerkseinlässe wir haben
zwei Triebwerke zwei eurojet Triebwerke
mit jeweils 55 Kilo Newton Schub und der
Möglichkeit noch den Nachbrenner zu
zünden der Nachbrenner nichts anderes
wie das der Flieger viel viel mehr
Leistung bekommt wir kommen dann vor 55
Kilonewton auf 90 Kilonewton zusammen
mal zwei 18 Tonnen Schub man kann sich
das so vorstellen wie war mein Auto
sitzt das Gaspedal ganz durch und auf
einmal doppelt so viel PS und damit man
es ist besser vorstellen kann unsere
straßenbes von den Triebwerken werden
ungefähr 150.000 Auto pS Das ist sehr
sinnvoll für
Kampf für das dass ich Höhen schnell
erreiche und das brauchen wir vor allem
in der täglichen Überwachung dass wir
eventuelle zielluftfahrzeuge schnell
interpretieren sprich schnell
beamtshandeln können
so die Triebwerke wir können 5 Tonnen
Sprit im Flieger mitnehmen der Flieger
hat ungefähr 11 Tonnen als Lehre er kann
maximal 23,5 Tonnen schwer werden bis 5
Tonnen internen Kraftstoff haben wir
dann nur siebeneinhalb Tonnen zur
Verfügung welcher wir auf den Flieger
als Außenlasten draufhängen können in
Form von maßstabkörper intelligenten
Bomben sprich cederms
Mittelstreckenraketen
Kurzstreckenraketen und natürlich die
Bordkanone und diese schauen wir uns in
weiterer Folge an an der linken Seite
des Rumpfes befindet sich unsere
Maschinenkanone seine integrierte 27mm
Kanone wir haben 150 Schuss mit und die
kadenzzahl ungefähr 30 Schuss in der
Sekunde das heißt die Kanone schießt
sehr sehr schnell das brauchen wir vor
allem um Ziele im luftkampfbekämpfen zu
können des Weiteren haben wir an der
Unterseite des Flugzeuges sprich an den
Tragflügel als auch am Bälle am Bauch
des Fliegers 13 Aufhängepunkte für
diverse Außenlasten die wir
transportieren können gesagt das ist
angefangen von Marschflugkörper über
Raketen Bomben bis hin zu aussentanks
wir haben fünf Tonnen Sprit innen und
können nochmal zwei Tonnen Kraftstoff an
den
außenlaststationen tragen diese
möglichst uns eine Flugzeit von über 3
Stunden
hier auf der linken Seite sehen Sie den
itzpel sehr kompliziert an ist es aber
nicht ist einfach eine Aufhängung für
die Hauptbewaffnung in unserer
friedenszeitlichen luftrömung
Überwachung nämlich den airpolising sie
ist die Iris t ein Hitze Suchende Waffe
ein infrared imaging system telefressed
das heißt man kann sie das vorstellen
wie bei topgun jetzt waren der fliegt
und der hört seinen Ton wenn er den
Gegner bekämpfen will das ist genau
diese Waffe das heißt ich brauche einen
Ton der Suchkopf braucht einen Ton und
danach trifft er auch
weiters ist auf diesem Kitzbühel sind
unsere Gegenmaßnahmen montiert wenn man
unten rein schaut dann können wir noch
an dann reinschauen sind die sogenannten
Chefs installiert Chefs sind nichts
anderes wie Aluminium Beutel die
ausgestoßen werden von uns die haben
dieselbe Radarsignatur wieder Flieger
und schützen uns davor von radarwaffen
getroffen zu werden weiter innen haben
wir noch Flair Aufhängungen Flairs sind
gegen Hitze Suchende Raketen das haben
Phosphor Kugeln die wir auch auf Befehl
ausstoßen können die die ähnliche oder
dieselbe Hitze Signatur haben wie die
Triebwerke von Flieger und somit die
feindlichen Raketen täuschen können
weiters haben wir am rechten winktipp
nämlich hier drinnen die Kreis nennt man
das das enttäuscht Körper die wir
ausstoßen können die dann mit einem Seil
am Flieger nachgezogen werden und ein
zweites Ziel simulieren das heißt wir
sind damit fähig eine Waffe abzulenken
die kommen hier hinten raus wir ziehen
Sie ein paar Meter paar 100 Meter hinter
uns her und die Rakete wird damit
getäuscht zum ausstoßen der Flairs
sprich ist zuerst der Chefs die
schmeißen wir hier raus spricht gegen
radarwaffen verteidigen wir uns hiermit
oder hiermit und gegen Infrarot Suchende
Waffen haben wir die ausschlussöffnungen
da unten genau beim Fahrrad
weiterhin wie gesagt 13 Aufhängepunkte
wir haben supersonic fuel tanks das
heißt wir können auch mit den
Außenlasten in den überall gehen das ist
für den Flieger überhaupt kein Problem
aufgrund der enormen Stärke der
Triebwerke und deren dynamischen
Eigenschaften ist es in den Überschall
gehen ganz ganz einfach es ist für uns
tatsächlich nur eine Zahl es passiert im
Cockpit relativ wenig der Flieger greift
gleich das aufgrund seiner Sensoren und
mit den Computern aus dass wir uns
permanent ein angenehmes Fluggefühl
entsteht das Gute ist auch wir sitzen
vor den Schall das heißt wir hören den
überall Knall nicht als nächstes
befinden wir uns am Leitwerk
grundsätzlich haben wir hier den Exhaus
der Triebwerke das heißt hier wird
einfach die heiße Luft nachdem sie
verbrannt ist wieder ausgestoßen des
Weiteren befinden sich hier hinten
drinnen unser Fallschirm unser
Bremsschirm ehrlicherweise
und unser Fanghaken der Eurofighter kann
auf verschiedene Arten zum Stillstand
gebracht werden natürlich beim Landen
mit den will bricks sprich mit dem
Bremsen wie man es vom Auto gewöhnt ist
dass man einfach in die Bremsen steigt
und der Flieger wird langsamer die
zweite Möglichkeit ist dass wir hier
einen Bremsschirm auswerfen da geht dann
hinterm Flieger auf und funktioniert
quasi wie ein Fallschirm nur in der
horizontalen Ebene und dritte ist hier
unten ist ein Haken drauf wir haben in
Zeltweg zwei fangkabeln das heißt wir
können mit dem Eurofighter so landen wie
ein Kampfjet auf einem
flugzeugträgerland ist kommt ein Haken
herunter wir gehen ins Seil und stehen
dann innerhalb von wenigen Metern
auf der linken Seite des Fliegers
schauen wir uns jetzt noch einmal genau
unsere Steuerflächen an aufgrund der
aerodynamischen Eigenschaften als
delta-flügler ist der Eurofighter nicht
so aufgebaut werden normales Flugzeug
wie man es vielleicht kennt den
Passagierflugzeug zum Beispiel der
Eurofighter hat eine finde ein
Seitenleitwerk über dem wir uns über die
Hochachse stabilisieren das heißt der
Flieger wird zum Gehirn gebracht des
Weiteren haben wir kein Höhenleitwerk
der Flieger hat hier an den Tragflächen
hinterseiten
zwei Klappen montiert die fungieren
gleichzeitig als höhenruderquerruder und
als Landeklappen das heißt der Flieger
der Flight Control Computer und ich
einen Input gebe zum Beispiel ich möchte
nach rechts Rollen suchte der Flieger
die Steuerflächen aus der gerade dazu
braucht und steuert diese an
auf der linken Seite befindet sich auch
noch unser ECM Pot hört sich wieder
kompliziert an da ist sie einfach diese
electronic Counter Messer Pot das heißt
er beschützt uns vor Gefahren im
elektromagnetischen Spektrum
dieses Gerät schafft es andere Flugzeuge
zu täuschen das heißt wir kommen in
einen Vorteil er kann falsche Ziele
projizieren da kann das stören und so
weiter je nachdem was für eine Datenbank
geladen ist und was wir vorhin von ihm
wollen so unterstützt uns dieser bot gut
weiter von unserem isynt geht es über
die linke Vorderseite des Flugzeuges hin
zum Cockpit grundsätzlich gleich die
linke Seite der rechten Seite abgesehen
von den Link Tipps identisch an den
Vorderseiten der Tragflächen haben wir
sogenanntes letzte helfen uns dabei mehr
auftritt zu erzeugen und auch im
Kurvenradius enger zu werden falls wir
das benötigen wir haben ein
dreipunktfahrwerk ist das der
Eurofighter sitzt immer auf dem
Hauptfahrwerk auf und senkt dann erst
das Buch Fahrwerk ab des Weiteren sieht
man hier am belli eingemacht gewisse
Ausnehmungen von denen haben wir vier
Stück hier würde eine Allwetter Waffe
Platz haben wenn wir diese benötigen
würden als nächstes bevor wir in den
Arbeitsplatz des Piloten kommen nämlich
ins Cockpit gehen wir noch kurz über die
Ausrüstung eines Eurofighter Piloten
drüber bis ihr seht stehe ich nicht im
normalen fluchtdienstanzug für euch
sondern ich brauche relativ viel
Zusatzausrüstung aufgrund von der
Geschwindigkeiten der gehkräfte die auf
mich wirken und der Höhe damit im
Eurofighter bei Bewusstsein und am Leben
bleibe bei Eurofighter kann
grundsätzlich bis weit in die
Stratosphäre vordringen sprich wir
befinden uns hier in der Troposphäre und
eine Atmosphärenschicht drüber bis
dorthin können wir mit Eurofighter
fliegen wir brauchen daher
sehr viel versorgt und die Versorgung
basiert durch unser aja das Air Crew
Equipment des simply wir sind damit mit
dem Flieger verbunden bekommen durch die
diversen Schläuche und Anschlüsse alles
was wir zum Überleben brauchen sprich
Druckluft Atemluft und Strom für die
gesamte Ausrüstung von unten nach oben
stecke ich in einer gehose an die g-hose
hat diesen Grund dass der Eurofighter
auf +9 bis -3g beschleunigen kann plus
9g kann man sie etwas so vorstellen so
wie wir zum Boden stehen haben wir
eingehe die einfache erdanzierungskraft
das heißt ich mit meiner Ausrüstung habe
ungefähr 100 Kilo wenn ich jetzt zum
Flieger anziehe im Kurven im Flug z.B
beschleunige auf +9g das heißt ich werde
9 mal so schwer ich wiege dann fast eine
Tonne bei diesem Belastungen bewegt sich
alles was im Körper nicht fest verankert
ist sprich alles außer die Knochen
Richtung unten das blöde ist das auch
das Blut aus dem Gehirn rausfließt und
da das Gehirn ohne Blut nicht arbeiten
kann wäre es von Vorteil wenn das Gehirn
dort bleibt dafür haben wir die Hose bei
anliegender Beschleunigung schnürt diese
g-hose meine Beine ab und drückt mir in
den Bauchraum hinein wobei meine Muskeln
von alleine aus Reflex angespannt werden
somit wird eine Barriere erstellt und
das Blut kann nicht mehr die Beine
versacken Weiteren haben wir die Weste
an die sie erzeugt einen Druck auf den
Brustkorb aus demselben Prinzip wir
haben dann aber unsere
lebensausrüstungen drinnen ist erklären
wir euch gerne in einem anderen Video
und was wir uns auch noch sehr wichtig
ist wir haben Cockpit jetzt keinen
Schreibtisch oder sonst irgendwas wir
können uns quasi kein Buch irgendwo
hinlegen drum haben wir unser Büro auf
den kniebrettern mit hier haben wir
sämtliche Informationen drinnen die
vielleicht im Flug brauchen könnte
sprich diverse Anflugverfahren diverse
zahlen die für diverse Taktiken benötige
bis hin zu Wirbel warnings die
irgendwann aufsagen muss wenn ihr eine
Amtshandlung in der Luft vornehme da wir
beide in der Stratosphäre fliegen und
dort der Luftdruck einfach zu gering ist
für Menschen dass der dabei Bewusstsein
bleiben kann bzw Bewusstsein kann er
bleiben ja aber er ist geistig wie ein
Kleinkind müssen wir beatmet werden vom
Flieger und dies geschieht über die
Sauerstoffmaske in unserem Helm wir
haben ein eigenes System im Flieger das
ist onboard oxygeneration System das
heißt der Flieger erzeugt für uns
Sauerstoff und verabreicht die uns dann
in einer atembahn Luft mit der exakten
luftdichte und damit wir bei Bewusstsein
bleiben
genug zur Ausrüstung jetzt schauen wir
uns den Arbeitsplatz eines Eurofighter
Piloten nämlich das Cockpit genau an
gut herzlich willkommen im copit des
Eurofighters diese Sets ist der
Eurofighter ein single-siedler das heißt
wir befinden uns alleine im Flugzeug wir
haben kein Fluglärm mit jeder ist für
seinen Flieger selbst verantwortlich man
muss sich quasi auf sich selbst
verlassen zum Cockpit Design ist eher
sechs ist der Steuerknüppel relativ
riesig der Flieger ist grundsätzlich auf
ein Hot das Prinzip aufgebaut das heißt
hands on Trottel in Stick ich kann den
gesamten Flieger alle wichtigen Sachen
die ich im Luftkampf brauche Steuern
einfach nur über den kontrollstick und
dem Leistungshebel hat den Grund dass
man wie gesagt bis 9 g erreichen können
und
ob ungefähr 2G kann man nicht mehr die
Gliedmaßen lassen sich nicht mehr heben
weil es einfach zu schwer werden es muss
sich das quasi alles was ich brauche für
den Luftkampf so erreichen dass ich
meine Hände nicht mehr bewegen muss
nicht mehr heben muss vom Cockpit Layout
wir haben drei MSDS das
place das heißt wir nehmen unsere
Informationen die wir fürs Fliegen
brauchen
von den drei Bildschirmen herum und
unser Hauptinstrument ist das head up
Display das ist diese Scheibe hier
kannst du das Vorstellen man sieht die
gesamte Welt einfach nur grün hinterlegt
mit sämtlichen Daten die gerade für
meinen Flug brauche natürlich sitzen wir
auch im Eurofighter Cockpit nicht auf
einen normalen Sitz sondern auf einem
Schleudersitz ich befinde mich hier auf
dem Martin bakersitz das ist ein
sogenannter 00-sitz der schleudersitzer
quasi die Möglichkeit dass wenn ich mich
im Boden Nähe mit 90 Grad Querlage aus
dem Flieger rausschießen würde würde
mich der Sitz retten das heißt ich würde
es überleben sind sehr intelligenter
Sitz wir haben Arm entlegress trains das
heißt der Sitz fängt uns fängt unsere
Gliedmaßen ein und fixiert sie am sitzen
das hat folgenden Hintergrund wir können
mit dem Eurofighter über 2000 km/h
schnell werden ungefähr 2500 km/h die
Zweieinhalbfache Schallgeschwindigkeit
jeder hat schon mal beim Auto bei 50 60
km/h vielleicht die Hand aus dem Fenster
gehalten und da gemerkt dass es sehr
ungut ist mit Luftzug war nicht sonder
km/h vor ist es wichtig unangenehme tut
beizeiten wie man kann sich vorstellen
was bei zweieinhalbtausend km/h mit den
Gliedmaßen passieren würde des Weiteren
haben wir am Schleudersitz eine EUB
nennen wir das eine auxilery oxygen
bottle das heißt wenn man kleine
Sauerstoffflasche mit durch das wir also
extreme Höhen erreichen können Kinder
wird dort die Umgebungsluft nicht warten
das heißt wir müssen versorgt werden bis
dass wir in eine Sauerstoff oder in eine
luftdichtere Atmosphärenschicht gefallen
sind und dort kann sie dann der
Schleudersitz sprich der Fallschirm
entfachen und bremst dann unseren Fall
und wir kommen gut am Boden an
falls ihr Interesse habt beim Bundesheer
Pilot zu werden vom Eurofighter benutzt
zu werden dann meldet euch an der
angegebenen Adresse unten denn
Eurofighter fliegen beim Bundesheer ist
wie Top Gun nur viel cooler und jetzt
nehme ich Euch mit auf einen
Trainingsflug quer durch die Republik
[Musik]